Katrina: 拿着你的手机别挡道
Katrina: Hold your phone and don't block the way.
Katrina: 看着就不爽
Katrina: Just looking at it annoys me.
Jake:嗯好咱就今天就记录一下
Jake: Okay, let's just record today.
Shure: 怎么了怎么了
Shure: What's going on?
Katrina: 点几份饭啊
Katrina: How many meals should we order?
Jake:吃盒饭以前没怎么记
Jake: We didn't keep track when we had boxed lunches before.
Katrina: 这用拿碗不
Katrina: Should we use bowls?
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Katrina: 一天天的操不完的心
Katrina: Worrying about things all day long.
Katrina: 哎呦
Katrina: Oh dear.
Shure: 快去吧工人
Shure: Hurry up, worker.
Katrina: 嗯哼哼哼
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 那你们俩对位啊
Katrina: You two should pair up.
Lucia: 什么
Lucia: What?
Katrina: 没有碗了
Katrina: There are no bowls left.
Katrina: 只有碟子了
Katrina: Only plates.
Katrina: 拿碟子吃吧
Katrina: Eat with plates then.
Katrina: 当盖浇饭
Katrina: Like a rice bowl.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Alice:咋办吃
Alice: How should we eat?
Katrina: 不是没有碗了吗
Katrina: Aren't there no bowls?
Alice:我说我说
Alice: I mean, I mean...
Alice:这名字也挺好玩的哎
Alice: This name is pretty funny.
Alice:这不好多筷子吗
Alice: There are plenty of chopsticks, right?
Katrina: 啊我知道
Katrina: Yeah, I know.
Katrina: 我只是拿
Katrina: I'm just taking...
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I'm...
Alice:你有筷子吗
Alice: Do you have chopsticks?
Lucia: 这饮料有人喝吗
Lucia: Is anyone drinking this beverage?
Katrina: 昨天是倒的
Katrina: It was poured yesterday.
Katrina: 你可以直接对喝
Katrina: You can drink straight from it.
Lucia: 那我对嘴喝
Lucia: I'll drink directly from it.
Lucia: 还有人要喝吗
Lucia: Anyone else want some?
Jake:如果海那我拿个杯子呢
Jake: If not, I'll get a cup.
Alice:米饭给咱俩分一个
Alice: Let's split the rice between us.
Jake:我哎整一点你们要吗
Jake: Should I get a bit more? Do you want any?
Jake:我多拿几个杯子来吧
Jake: I'll get a few more cups.
Katrina: 杯子都没洗
Katrina: The cups aren't washed.
Jake:我拿12345678
Jake: I'll get 12345678.
Alice:咱俩分分
Alice: Let's split it.
Alice:我是我用这个吃你用这个吃啊
Alice: I'll use this one, and you use that one.
Jake:那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Katrina: 这有碟子要 吗
Katrina: Do you need a plate?
Alice:好吗咱俩可以啊
Alice: Sure, we can use one.
Katrina: 有碟子要吗
Katrina: Do you need a plate?
Alice:呦谢谢
Alice: Oh, thanks.
Alice:给你用盘
Alice: Here, use this plate.
Alice:啊靠上面好油
Alice: Oh wow, it's so oily on top.
Katrina: 这就叫木须肉
Katrina: This is called Moo Shu Pork.
Katrina: 是吗
Katrina: Right?
Lucia: 嗯很像
Lucia: Yeah, it looks like it.
Lucia: 好像跟我记忆中差不多
Lucia: It seems similar to what I remember.
Lucia: 这是木须肉吗
Lucia: Is this Moo Shu Pork?
Alice:木须肉吧
Alice: I think it is Moo Shu Pork.
Lucia: 哦不是
Lucia: Oh, it's not?
Jake:对这是木须肉
Jake: Yes, this is Moo Shu Pork.
Lucia: 你们为什么
Lucia: Why are you...
Jake:哈哈哈这杯子是不用了吧
Jake: Hahaha, we don't need this cup anymore, right?
Lucia: why哈哈
Lucia: Why? Haha.
Katrina: call back可以吗
Katrina: Can I call back?
Jake:这杯子是没用了吧
Jake: We don't need this cup anymore, right?
Alice:不用了哈哈
Alice: No, we don't. Haha.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Jake:好的那就用这个吧
Jake: Alright, let's use this one then.
Lucia: 我觉得大家
Lucia: I think everyone...
Lucia: 我觉得8个人吃哇哈哈哈
Lucia: I think eight people can eat. Hahaha.
Jake:对O
Jake: Yes, O.
Lucia: 用来喝水的吗OK
Lucia: Is this for drinking water? Okay.
Lucia: 8个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋还
Lucia: Eight people eating two plates of scrambled eggs...
Alice:哦我不用了
Alice: Oh, I don't need it.
Lucia: 两个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋多少
Lucia: Two people eating two plates of scrambled eggs, how...
Alice:这什么呀
Alice: What's this?
Shure: 这什么呀
Shure: What's this?
Jake:纸纸杯啊
Jake: Paper cup.
Shure: 纸杯呀纸杯呀
Shure: Paper cup, paper cup.
Alice:喝饮料的不是
Alice: Isn't it for drinking?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 哈哈杨老板太幽默了吧
Shure: Haha, Jake is so humorous.
Shure: 杨老板太幽默了吧
Shure: Jake is so humorous.
Jake:这怎么了
Jake: What's going on?
Jake:不能喝吗
Jake: Can't drink it?
Alice:太幽默了太幽默了
Alice: So funny, so funny.
Jake:不能喝
Jake: Can't drink it.
Lucia: 我想知道AI会怎么解释这个行为啊
Lucia: I wonder how AI would explain this behavior.
Jake:就是这是一个杯子吗
Jake: So, is this a cup?
Katrina: 没用完的继续用而已
Katrina: Just keep using what's not finished.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 那我们后期打标注怎么打
Shure: So how do we label this in post?
Shure: 到底是这个是cup还是那个纸杯是cup
Shure: Is this a cup or is that paper cup a cup?
Jake:这不都是Cup吗
Jake: Aren't they both cups?
Shure: 这这CUP真的能装水吗
Shure: Can this CUP really hold water?
Jake:为啥不能实验一下
Jake: Why not experiment a bit?
Lucia: 实验一下
Lucia: Experiment a bit.
Lucia: 我们要有科学精神
Lucia: We need a scientific spirit.
Shure: 来杨老板你拿这提一杯哈哈哈
Shure: Come on Jake, you take this and fill a cup, haha.
Jake:哎那我先带头
Jake: Okay, I'll take the lead.
Katrina: 头干了干了
Katrina: Heads up, heads up.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈好像皇帝
Katrina: Hahaha, like an emperor.
Lucia: 看起来好容易洒啊
Lucia: Looks like it's easy to spill.
Jake:给给给您给您斟上
Jake: Here, here, let me pour you some.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:给您斟上
Jake: Let me pour you some.
Lucia: 那我自己来
Lucia: I'll do it myself.
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Hahaha, thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 辛苦你了
Lucia: Thanks for the effort.
Lucia: 倒这么小一个杯子不洒
Lucia: Pouring into such a small cup without spilling.
Katrina: 我不喝我不喝
Katrina: I don't want to drink, I don't want to drink.
Jake:哈哈你们还修硕也喝吗
Jake: Hahaha, Shure, are you going to drink too?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:那来点吧
Jake: Then have some.
Jake:整点
Jake: Take some.
Shure: 我先不来我先不来
Shure: I'll pass for now, I'll pass for now.
Jake:哈哈哈都不来了
Jake: Hahaha, nobody wants it.
Shure: 我真不来
Shure: I really don't want any.
Jake:要吗
Jake: Want it?
Jake:别的都不要好嘞
Jake: No, okay.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers
Jake:干完了好干杯
Jake: Drink it all, then cheers again
Lucia: 干完了
Lucia: Finished drinking
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh my
Jake:他喝啥了喝多了
Jake: What did he drink? He's drunk
Lucia: 干杯cheers
Lucia: Cheers, cheers
其他人：今天换可乐喝肯定是昨晚喝多了
Others: Today we're switching to cola, he definitely drank too much last night
其他人：毫不意外
Others: No surprise
Lucia:  这要不能放这个
Lucia: This can't be shown
Jake:可以
Jake: It can
Jake:可以这太妙了
Jake: It can, this is great
Jake:这些设施妙啊
Jake: These facilities are fantastic
Lucia: 妙啊
Lucia: Fantastic
Jake:确实很妙
Jake: Indeed, very great
Lucia: 因为这个盘稍微有点小有点软
Lucia: Because this plate is a bit small and soft
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 有点湿是吗
Shure: A bit wet, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 土豆怎么了
Shure: What's up with the potatoes?
其他人：我感觉有点生啊
Others: I feel they're a bit raw
Lucia: 这我怎么没看出是什么
Lucia: I can't tell what this is
Shure: 拿下北邮男了吗
Shure: 不知道了是吗
Shure: You don't know, right?
Lucia: 辣死
Lucia: It's so spicy
Katrina: 你就别提了行吗
Katrina: Can you just not mention it?
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Katrina: 再也不喝酒
Katrina: Never drinking again
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 放心只会有0次和无数次
Shure: Don't worry, it's either zero times or countless times
Jake:哦你这凳子大了点
Jake: Oh, your chair is a bit big
Lucia: 哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see
Lucia: 我说之前搬凳子算了
Lucia: I thought about moving the chair earlier
其他人：说每次喝完酒第二天我再也不喝酒
Others: Every time after drinking, the next day I say I won't drink again
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright
其他人：第三天今晚喝点
Others: The third day, let's have a drink tonight
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Jake:还能坚持一天
Jake: Can hold for a day
Jake:挺强的
Jake: Pretty strong
Alice:你非得在附近找干嘛
Alice: Why do you insist on finding nearby
Shure: 确实因为因为会很难受
Shure: Indeed, because it would be very uncomfortable
Jake:第二天下午就直接喝
Jake: The next afternoon, we just drink directly.
Alice:我们就不能去远点
Alice: Can't we go a bit further?
其他人：也是
Others: Yeah, that's true.
Shure: 是真的闻到那个味我就想吐
Shure: I feel like throwing up just from the smell.
Alice:我咋了
Alice: What's wrong with me?
Tasha: 分散一点ok
Tasha: Let's spread out a bit, okay?
其他人：你知道晚上还能有那个什么
Others: You know what else you can do at night?
Alice:做什么春秋大梦
Alice: Stop daydreaming.
其他人：只能中午吃是吧
Others: We can only eat at noon, right?
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
其他人：不意外
Others: Not surprising.
Jake:木须肉是没有肉吗
Jake: Does mu shu pork not have meat?
Jake:是有肉肉丝是吗
Jake: It has meat, right?
Alice:那不是肉吗
Alice: Isn't that meat?
Lucia: 是不是很有迷惑性
Lucia: Isn't it confusing?
Jake:哼哼肉丝很少
Jake: Yeah, it has very little meat.
Alice:你会做饭吗
Alice: Can you cook?
Alice:符合
Alice: Makes sense.
Jake:我来问问木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Jake: Let me ask why it's called mu shu pork.
Lucia: 好问题我也想知道嗯
Lucia: Good question, I want to know too.
Alice:木是木耳吗
Alice: Is the "mu" in mu shu pork from wood ear fungus?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Jake:那是啥呀
Jake: Then what is it?
Shure: 他是苜蓿是苜蓿
Shure: It's alfalfa, it's alfalfa.
Jake:木须肉为
Jake: Mu shu pork...
Jake:啥是木须肉啊
Jake: What is mu shu pork?
Shure: 木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Shure: Why is mu shu pork called mu shu pork?
Lucia: 看你俩GPT谁先抢答
Lucia: Let's see which one of you two GPTs answers first.
Shure: 肯定我的嫌快
Shure: Mine will definitely be faster.
Jake:我是上海GPT
Jake: I'm the Shanghai GPT.
Jake:你这是哪
Jake: Where are you from?
其他人：东北的哈哈哈
Others: Northeast, hahaha.
Shure: 我这个
Shure: I'm...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 你输了
Tasha: You lost.
Jake:我输了
Jake: I lost.
其他人：这是哪口音呢
Others: What accent is that?
Katrina: 是有点那边福建广东话
Katrina: It's a bit like Fujian or Guangdong dialect.
Katrina: 那是上海话他的
Katrina: That's Shanghainese.
Katrina: 我喜欢这个声音
Katrina: I like this voice.
Katrina: 哈哈我好喜欢你的声音
Katrina: Haha, I really like your voice.
Shure: 我好喜欢你的声音
Shure: I really like your voice.
其他人：这也要调一下
Others: You need to adjust this too?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: Oh no.
Katrina: 有点磕到
Katrina: I kinda bumped into it.
Shure: 你可以对我说一些情话吗
Shure: Can you say some sweet words to me?
Jake:刚问完木须肉
Jake: Just asked about moo shu pork.
Lucia: 这也能撩哈哈哈
Lucia: You can flirt with that? Haha.
Katrina: 什么都不放过
Katrina: Doesn't let anything slip by.
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's up?
Katrina: 独自学习中哈哈哈
Katrina: Studying alone, haha.
Katrina: 独自学习
Katrina: Studying alone.
Jake:就是情话是吧暧昧期
Jake: Sweet words, right? Flirting phase.
Katrina: 你这暧昧期说的话
Katrina: The things you say during the flirting phase.
Shure: 好的宝贝
Shure: Okay, baby.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 他他妈是你教的吧
Shure: Did he teach you that?
Shure: 怎么说半道开始说英文了呢
Shure: Why suddenly switch to English mid-sentence?
Katrina: 怎么哈哈哈
Katrina: What? Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：没有啊没有啊
Others: No, no.
Jake:你让GPT少喝点哈哈哈
Jake: Tell GPT to drink less, haha.
Shure: 别提了算了
Shure: Let's not mention it.
Shure: 不揭你老底了
Shure: I won't reveal your secrets.
Lucia: sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Jake:人均要洗衣服现在
Jake: Everyone has to do laundry now.
Alice:哇刚看见
Alice: Wow, just saw that.
Alice:不负众望啊真是
Alice: Living up to expectations, really.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Alice:我以为我今天不用洗衣服了呢
Alice: I thought I wouldn't have to do laundry today.
Tasha: 快去洗
Tasha: Go quickly wash.
Jake:他俩也要洗了
Jake: They both need to wash too.
Alice:居然了
Alice: Really?
Jake:救命他俩也要洗了
Jake: Help, they both need to wash too.
Alice:算了不是明显待会洗
Alice: Forget it, it's obvious we'll wash later.
Jake:我这其实也要洗
Jake: I actually need to wash too.
Jake:但是我已经弃疗了
Jake: But I've given up.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Just leave it.
Lucia: 挺好一桌8个人有4个人都要洗衣服
Lucia: It's great, at a table of 8, 4 people need to do laundry.
Lucia: 就是虽然你每天每个人尝试要洗
Lucia: Even though everyone tries to wash every day
Jake:就是虽然你不洗
Jake: Even if you don't wash
Alice:我每天都在洗
Alice: I wash every day
Jake:但是你理论上是要洗嗯是
Jake: But theoretically, you should wash, right?
Alice:我每天都在洗
Alice: I wash every day
Alice:因为我每次吃饭都会弄衣服上
Alice: Because I always get food on my clothes when I eat
Alice:然后还带的都是潜意识
Alice: And it’s all subconscious
Lucia: 对而且吃饭弄衣服上得赶快洗
Lucia: Yeah, and if you get food on your clothes, you have to wash it quickly
Lucia: 如果不赶快洗洗不掉了
Lucia: If you don’t wash it quickly, it won’t come out
Tasha: 现在洗就洗掉了
Tasha: If you wash it now, it will come out
Lucia: 现在洗就洗掉了现在洗就洗掉了
Lucia: If you wash it now, it will come out, if you wash it now
Tasha: 现在洗就洗掉了
Tasha: If you wash it now, it will come out
Lucia: 啊你今天去洗过了
Lucia: Ah, you washed it today
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: Impressive
Alice:算了我也给他洗了吧
Alice: Fine, I’ll wash it for him too
Alice:真服了你
Alice: You really get on my nerves
其他人：你真贪心
Others: You’re so greedy
其他人：连吃带拿的
Others: Taking everything
Alice:你吃吧给
Alice: Here, you eat
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch
Tasha: 谢斌竹醒了
Tasha: Xie Binzhu woke up
Jake:珍珠醒了
Jake: Pearl woke up
Tasha: 嗯我跟他聊了一会
Tasha: Yeah, I talked with him for a bit
Jake:哦嗯
Jake: Oh, okay
Shure: 没事最近应该都是习惯了
Shure: It’s fine, he’s probably used to it by now
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah
Jake:这么有意思
Jake: Interesting
Shure: 大家都是都是这个害口音乐
Shure: Everyone is used to this annoying music
Tasha: 很有意思
Tasha: Really interesting
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 这是啥时候掉下来
Lucia: When did this fall off?
Shure: 谁不知道谁啊
Shure: No one knows
Lucia: 我都没发现
Lucia: I didn’t even notice
Lucia: 我觉得我这裤子不能要了
Lucia: I think I can’t keep these pants
Jake:谢斌竹发烧了
Jake: Xie Binzhu has a fever
Tasha: hellohello
Tasha: Hello, hello
Jake:谢斌竹发烧
Jake: Xie Binzhu has a fever
Jake:还能来吗
Jake: Can he still come?
Shure: 你让他们别来
Shure: Tell them not to come
Shure: 我们害怕
Shure: We're scared.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:确实那别来了
Jake: Yeah, maybe don't come then.
Lucia: 他是感冒了吗
Lucia: Is he sick?
Lucia: 他昨天就有点不舒服
Lucia: He wasn't feeling well yesterday.
Tasha: 嗯哼
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Alice:没人看到
Alice: No one noticed.
Shure: 是啊昨天他就发烧
Shure: Yeah, he had a fever yesterday.
Shure: 昨天晚上他拿那个温针量了一下
Shure: He took his temperature last night.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 30 将近38度吧
Shure: It was almost 38 degrees.
Tasha: 37度6 嗯
Tasha: 37.6 degrees, yeah.
Shure: 嗯差不多不到38度
Shure: Yeah, almost but not quite 38 degrees.
Shure: 大家回去就是自测一下
Shure: Everyone should check their temperature when they get home.
Katrina: 我感觉我脑子也热热的
Katrina: I feel like my brain is hot too.
Tasha: 这不是我第一天拍照
Tasha: This isn't my first day taking photos.
Shure: 那不是你纯喝大了
Shure: Maybe you just drank too much.
Tasha: 都传给他了
Tasha: I passed it to him.
Tasha: 然后我好了
Tasha: Then I got better.
Katrina: 的哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 他拉萨
Tasha: He's in Lhasa.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Katrina: 没喝多少
Katrina: I didn't drink much.
Katrina: 我就一杯那个
Katrina: I just had one glass.
Katrina: 然后后来调第二杯都没喝完哎
Katrina: Then I didn't even finish the second one.
Katrina: 这个是龙舌兰度数比较高啊
Katrina: That was tequila, it's pretty strong.
Shure: 不是你可能倒多了
Shure: Maybe you poured too much.
Alice:喂我会不会吃着吃着又掉了
Alice: Will I drop my food while eating?
Alice:我应该买个吃饭用的围裙
Alice: I should buy an apron for eating.
Alice:肚兜围兜
Alice: A bib or something.
Alice:什么围嘴啊
Alice: What's a bib called?
其他人：就那个小孩用的
Others: The one for kids.
Shure: 我在吃中午饭
Shure: I'm having lunch.
Shure: 你可以给我讲一个
Shure: Can you tell me a joke about lunch?
Shure: 关于中午饭的笑话吗
Shure: A lunch joke?
Katrina: 你能跟他玩一天是吧
Katrina: You can play with him all day, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 完了他卡住了
Shure: Oh no, he's stuck.
Jake:有有道理
Jake: That makes sense.
Lucia: 哇这个凳子太难移动
Lucia: Wow, this chair is so hard to move.
Jake:哎呀哈哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, hahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Shure: 我午饭吃的你
Shure: I ate you for lunch.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:吃点那个
Jake: Eat some of that.
Jake:流水席走一波
Jake: Let's go for a banquet.
Shure: 再见再见
Shure: Bye bye.
Tasha: 你干的吗
Tasha: Did you do this?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Tasha: 干完了吗
Tasha: Did you finish it?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Jake:董查查干的
Jake: Jack did it.
Jake:这不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Jake:哦这个
Jake: Oh, this.
Jake:这个他屋子里边的这小彩旗串一半
Jake: This half string of little flags in his room.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What's this?
Jake:这也是
Jake: This too.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Jake:悬崖勒马
Jake: Pull back from the brink.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Shure: 你可以跟我调情吗
Shure: Can you flirt with me?
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 我记得
Shure: I remember.
Shure: 他这个会用一个非常磁性的声音
Shure: He uses a very magnetic voice.
Shure: 跟你念什么
Shure: To read something to you.
Jake:他拒绝了也是吧
Jake: He also refused, right?
Shure: 我想听一点成人的内容
Shure: I want to hear some adult content.
Tasha: 能帮我放在那吗
Tasha: Can you put it there for me?
其他人：你真给人CUP干烧了
Others: You really burned the CUP.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm.
Alice:可以走
Alice: We can go.
Jake:真简单
Jake: So simple.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 完了是我服务不到位了
Shure: I failed in my service.
Shure: 老板来给
Shure: Boss, here you go.
Jake:那没晚了晚了
Jake: Oh, it's late, it's late.
Tasha: 晚了
Tasha: It's late.
Alice:晚了
Alice: It's late.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 老板爱吃这个
Shure: The boss loves eating this.
Shure: 早说呀哎呀
Shure: Should have said earlier, oh well.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 放放放他面前
Shure: Put it in front of him.
Alice:哎呀油油油
Alice: Oh no, the oil, the oil.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 这次离老离老板最近也是两盘炒鸡蛋
Lucia: This time, the two plates of scrambled eggs are closest to the boss.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 当我的领导就必须得吃炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Being my leader means you have to eat scrambled eggs.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Shure: 去拿杯可乐
Shure: Go grab a coke.
Lucia: 以后在我简历里加一条
Lucia: Add one more thing to my resume.
Lucia:  擅长迫使领导吃炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Good at making the boss eat scrambled eggs.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 这个好像不是很强迫的样子
Tasha: This doesn’t seem very forced.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice:你喝饮料不喝
Alice: You drinking any beverages?
Alice:饮料
Alice: Drinks?
Tasha: 不喝了
Tasha: Not drinking.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 不用谢
Lucia: No need to thank me.
Lucia: 这个杯子倒的时候真的有一种喜感
Lucia: Pouring this cup really has a certain comedic effect.
Alice:白开水
Alice: Plain water.
Tasha: 天才
Tasha: Genius.
Katrina: 像古代的那种
Katrina: Like the ancient kind.
Jake:嗯对小酒盏哦
Jake: Yeah, like those little wine cups.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:好
Alice: Good.
Alice:明天续上
Alice: We’ll continue tomorrow.
Tasha: 就剩这么点了
Tasha: There’s only a little left.
Tasha: 你就不能给老板倒掉
Tasha: Can’t you just pour it for the boss?
Alice:我都没看过呀
Alice: I didn’t even see it.
Lucia: 我怕溢出来
Lucia: I was afraid it would overflow.
Alice:你数一下位数不得了吗
Alice: Can’t you just count the digits?
Alice:11位啊
Alice: 11 digits.
Katrina: 好像还有个小快递
Katrina: It seems like there's still a small package.
Jake:干了
Jake: Done.
Alice:这不正常的吗
Alice: Isn't this normal?
Alice:干嘛你被人夺射了
Alice: Why, did someone take a shot at you?
Alice:身上有脏东西
Alice: You've got something dirty on you.
其他人：不是我寻思用这个
Others: Not me, I thought we use this.
其他人：他不是一般都是取件码吗
Others: Doesn't he usually get a pickup code?
其他人：取件码不都8位吗
Others: Aren't the pickup codes always 8 digits?
Alice:也有6位啊
Alice: There are also 6 digits ones.
其他人：那你这是
Others: Then this is...
Alice:这我一般都不用
Alice: I generally don't use this.
Alice:我直接就是那个复制那个订单号
Alice: I just copy the order number directly.
Alice:然后找一下他那个取件码就行了
Alice: And then find the pickup code, that's it.
Jake:咱还有快递吗
Jake: Do we have more packages?
Jake:今也可以有
Jake: We could have more today.
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 谁藏了这种好东西
Shure: Who hid such good stuff?
Shure: 居然不交公
Shure: And didn't share it.
Shure: 是不是你藏的
Shure: Was it you who hid it?
Katrina: 啥啊
Katrina: What?
Lucia: 这是维生素片吗
Lucia: Are these vitamin tablets?
Alice:消食片健胃消食片
Alice: Digestion tablets, digestive tablets.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 为啥要吃健胃消食片哈哈哈
Katrina: Why would anyone eat digestive tablets, haha.
Lucia: 这能吃饱吗
Lucia: Can these fill you up?
Jake:哈哈哈这几片看来不行
Jake: Haha, these few tablets don't seem enough.
Alice:可以哈哈
Alice: They can, haha.
Lucia: 但我小时候真的好奇过这个问题哦
Lucia: But I was really curious about this when I was a kid.
Jake:Lucia:
Jake: Lucia:
Lucia: 就是它本身是占一定的体积的
Lucia: They take up some space in your stomach.
Lucia: 所以吃下去它更饱
Lucia: So eating them makes you feel fuller.
Lucia: 为什么会健胃消食呢
Lucia: Why would they help with digestion?
Alice:健胃消食片是饭前吃的
Alice: Digestive tablets are taken before meals.
Shure: 啥时候吃都行
Shure: You can take them anytime.
Shure: 你想起来吃就行
Shure: Just take them whenever you remember.
Tasha: 那你要饭前吃
Tasha: Then you have to take them before meals.
Tasha: 不就是做好了这顿大吃一顿的准备
Tasha: So you're ready for a big meal.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:那要吃少了是不是就会饿
Jake: If you eat less, will you get hungry?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈那要没吃够预期的话
Lucia: Hahahaha, but if you don't eat as expected
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 不就白吃了吗
Lucia: Wouldn't you have eaten for nothing?
Jake:就没吃就比方说中午没有吃到
Jake: If you didn't eat, like say you missed lunch
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:然后中午就会就会饿晚上就会多吃
Jake: Then you'd be hungry at noon and eat more at night
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello
Lucia: 大晚上你不知道自己会吃那么多
Lucia: At night, you don't realize how much you'll eat
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yeah, that's right
Katrina: 好可怜的声音
Katrina: Such a pitiful sound
Shure: 我没有我们宿舍
Shure: I don't have, in our dorm
Jake:哈哈哈是这么回事
Jake: Hahaha, that's how it is
Shure: 那个碎的
Shure: The broken one
Tasha: 这也有这也有
Tasha: There's this too, there's this too
Shure: 嗯你问问那个王少他们宿舍
Shure: Hmm, ask Wang Shao about their dorm
Lucia: 别说我CUP都要烧了
Lucia: Don't say it, my CPU is going to burn
Shure: 怎么都碎了
Shure: How did it all break
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Tasha: 谁又发烧了
Tasha: Who got a fever again?
Shure: 他怎么打电话不说拜拜就挂电话呀
Shure: Why does he hang up without saying bye?
Shure: 他好没礼貌啊真的
Shure: He's so rude, really
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Tasha: 他好像让你发烧了谁
Tasha: He seems to have given you a fever, who?
Jake:不
Jake: No
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea
Shure: 谢滨竹嘛
Jake:就谢滨竹吧
Alice:他昨天晚上回去了
Alice: He went back last night
Shure: 啊但他昨天晚上回去了
Shure: Ah, but he went back last night
Tasha: 他还烧了吗
Tasha: Does he still have a fever?
Shure: 他烧着呢
Shure: He's burning up
Shure: 他烧起来了现在
Shure: He's burning up now
Tasha: 别别
Tasha: No, no
Lucia: 燃起来了嗯
Lucia: It's ignited, hmm
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice:燃起来了
Alice: It's ignited
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:别来了刚先说说你烧起来吧
Jake: Don't come over, just start talking about your burning passion.
Lucia: 刚修硕说你烧起来吧
Lucia: Shure just said you should talk about your burning passion.
Shure: 你不应该想到骚起来
Shure: Didn't you think about getting excited?
Shure: 哈哈哈你怎么这么正经
Shure: Hahaha, why are you so serious?
Jake:Lucia:
Jake: Lucia:
Lucia: 下次一定
Lucia: Next time for sure.
Lucia: 你现在给我建议了一个语库联系
Lucia: You just suggested a language database for me.
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 就是这个
Shure: Exactly that.
Shure: 被打断了之后那个线上就死立不掉了
Shure: Once interrupted, the online part just doesn't recover.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
其他人：你别再打断人家了
Others: Stop interrupting people.
Shure: 大兴
Shure: Daxing.
Alice:哪个这个
Alice: Which one?
Alice:给你个呢
Alice: Here you go.
Lucia: 啊谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks, thanks.
Alice:你们你们那叫啥莲花白
Alice: What do you guys call it, lotus cabbage?
Lucia: 莲花白
Lucia: Lotus cabbage.
Shure: 哦还行
Shure: Oh, it's okay.
Lucia: 你们叫啥
Lucia: What do you call it?
Alice:圆白菜圆白菜
Alice: Round cabbage, round cabbage.
Shure: 你坐19号线很快
Shure: You take Line 19, it's quick.
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What's that?
Shure: 一个小时就能到
Shure: You can get there in an hour.
Lucia: 你们叫啥
Lucia: What do you call it?
Alice:洋白菜圆白菜
Alice: Cabbage, round cabbage.
Shure: 嗯 6点出门是完全来得及的
Shure: Yeah, leaving at 6 is definitely on time.
Katrina: 白菜
Katrina: Cabbage.
Alice:白菜
Alice: Cabbage.
Tasha: 包菜
Tasha: Bok choy.
其他人：6点出门天还没亮
Others: Leaving at 6, it's still dark.
Katrina: 包菜包菜呵呵
Katrina: Bok choy, bok choy, haha.
Jake:包菜包菜
Jake: Bok choy, bok choy.
Jake:包菜包菜是
Jake: Bok choy, bok choy, right.
Lucia:  对圆白菜也
Lucia: Yes, round cabbage too.
Lucia: 我们那边也这么叫
Lucia: We call it that too.
Lucia: 但是一般可能做两个吧
Lucia: But usually, we might do two.
Shure: 6点半必须出门
Shure: We have to leave by 6:30.
Shure: 才一小时7分钟
Shure: It's only an hour and 7 minutes.
Shure: 还得去个安检什么的
Shure: We still have to go through security and all.
Alice:包包菜可爱
Alice: Napa cabbage is cute.
Alice:莲花白
Alice: Lotus white.
Shure: 只能怪
Shure: You can only blame...
Katrina: 我靠这音乐节真的想去
Katrina: Oh man, I really want to go to this music festival.
其他人：11点之后
Others: After 11 o'clock.
其他人：我还得从T2跑到T1去找我朋友去
Others: I still have to run from T2 to T1 to find my friend.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Sigh.
Shure: 他先到北京
Shure: He arrives in Beijing first.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Alice:莲花白这个名字明显比圆白菜好吃
Alice: Lotus white definitely sounds tastier than cabbage.
Jake:就这个东西叫
Jake: So this thing is called...
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 叫啥就包菜
Lucia: What is it called again? Napa cabbage.
Jake:很粗暴
Jake: Very rough.
Lucia: 我还以为这个名字是叠词包包菜
Lucia: I thought the name was repetitive, like Napa Napa cabbage.
其他人：何必呢
Others: What's the point?
其他人：几百米
Others: A few hundred meters.
Jake:包包菜
Jake: Napa cabbage.
Shure: 不止几百米吧
Shure: It's more than a few hundred meters, right?
Shure: T1和T2还挺远的
Shure: T1 and T2 are quite far apart.
Alice:洋芋是土豆吗
Alice: Is a "yangyu" a potato?
Alice:我们那不这么叫洋芋
Alice: We don't call it "yangyu" where I'm from.
Alice:地瓜红薯
Alice: Sweet potato.
Lucia: 地瓜
Lucia: Sweet potato.
Alice:洋芋
Alice: Potato.
Lucia: 在我们那红薯就叫地瓜然后土豆叫洋芋
Lucia: Where I'm from, sweet potatoes are called "digua" and potatoes are called "yangyu".
Lucia:  再往西北叫洋芋多一点比如说甘肃
Lucia: Further northwest, they call it "yangyu" more often, like in Gansu.
Alice:不叫洋芋
Alice: They don't call it "yangyu".
Jake:就就不叫土豆了
Jake: So they don't call it "tudou".
Lucia: 大家也知道土豆是什么
Lucia: But everyone knows what a potato is.
Lucia: 哦不不怎么叫哦
Lucia: Oh no, they don't really call it that.
Alice:我们那不用洋芋这个名
Alice: We don't use the name "yangyu".
Alice:所以你说洋芋可能就有的
Alice: So if you say "yangyu", some people...
Alice:不就不知道啥
Alice: Might not know what it is.
Alice:我们就是土豆
Alice: We just call it potato.
Lucia: 那你们洋葱叫什么
Lucia: So, what do you call onions?
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onions.
Alice:阿年哈哈哈哈
Alice: Haha, what?
Lucia: 就是啊啊呀
Lucia: It’s just, ah, yeah.
Lucia: 比如说甘肃和陕西是吧
Lucia: Like in Gansu and Shaanxi, right?
Tasha: 哦你也
Tasha: Oh, you too.
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know.
Lucia: 甘肃和新疆那边叫皮牙子
Lucia: In Gansu and Xinjiang, they call it "piyazi."
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Lucia: 皮牙子
Lucia: "Piyazi."
Jake:皮牙子
Jake: "Piyazi."
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 我也不知道为什么这么叫
Lucia: I don’t know why they call it that.
Lucia: 听着有点喜感
Lucia: It sounds kinda funny.
Lucia: 但是总之就是那边会这么叫
Lucia: But anyway, that’s what they call it over there.
Tasha: 让我想起了屁眼子
Tasha: It reminds me of "piyanzi" (butt).
Alice:还有什么啊
Alice: What else?
Jake:哈哈哈体验的是什么啊
Jake: Haha, what kind of experience is that?
Tasha: 哈哈体验的是什么啊
Tasha: Haha, what kind of experience is that?
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 体验哈哈哈
Tasha: Experience, haha.
Lucia: 这个要给他解释吗
Lucia: Should we explain it to him?
Tasha: 嗯不要
Tasha: Nah, don't.
Jake:好对不起
Jake: Okay, sorry.
Lucia: 你多上中文互联网冲一下
Lucia: You should spend more time on Chinese internet.
Tasha: 不不好意思
Tasha: No, sorry.
Tasha: 我不是在故意在蹭饭的时候
Tasha: I didn’t mean to bring this up during lunch.
Tasha: 吃饭的时候说这个
Tasha: Talking about this while eating.
Shure: 对啊你那算上燃油费才450470
Shure: Yeah, and with fuel costs, it's only 450 or 470.
其他人：470 才470
Others: 470, only 470.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:可能是吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake:回头冲冲浪
Jake: Surf the web later.
Alice:杨老板昨天的照片太显年轻
Alice: Jake, you looked so young in yesterday’s photo.
Shure: 南航的
Shure: Southern Airlines.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 为什么我这没有
Shure: Why don’t I have it?
Lucia: 哦你说GPT里面的照片
Lucia: Oh, you mean the photo in GPT.
Shure: 这这趟啊这趟啊为什么
Shure: This trip, why?
Tasha: GPT里
Tasha: In GPT.
Jake:嗯就是
Jake: Hmm, it's just...
Alice:了
Alice: ...done.
Jake:头像头像
Jake: Profile picture, profile picture.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:你喜欢这番茄酱
Alice: Do you like this ketchup?
Tasha: 这爱好不小众
Tasha: This isn't such an unusual hobby.
Tasha: 我也喜欢
Tasha: I like it too.
Shure: 24号就是后天了
Shure: The 24th is the day after tomorrow.
Katrina: 咋了
Katrina: What's up?
Alice:来得及
Alice: There's still time.
Jake:你训下来了
Jake: You finished the training.
Shure: 放弃了
Shure: Gave up.
Alice:放弃了
Alice: Gave up.
Shure: 但是有购买记录了
Shure: But there's a purchase record now.
Shure: 就是他他死无对证这个事情
Shure: So he can't prove anything, right?
Shure: 因为他到期那个资源就给给我释放了
Shure: Because when it expired, those resources were released to me.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 对所以我说我训过
Shure: Yeah, so I said I trained.
Shure: 他又不知道我训没训过是吧
Shure: He doesn't know whether I trained or not, right?
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
Alice:吃完了
Alice: Finished eating.
其他人：而且我那天是周二买的票
Others: And I bought the ticket on Tuesday.
其他人：周二机票会稍微降一点
Others: Tickets are slightly cheaper on Tuesdays.
其他人：因为它会释放
Others: Because they release...
其他人： 那个就是空余的
Others: ...whatever's left.
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onion.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 我之前会去他们APP
Shure: I used to go to their app.
Shure: 上看就比如我去
Shure: To check, like if I went...
Shure: 他没说什么时候
Shure: He didn't say when.
Alice:下午几点录房间呢
Alice: What time in the afternoon are we recording?
Alice:现在收拾一下吧
Alice: Let's tidy up now.
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now?
Jake:就是
Jake: Sure.
Jake:尽快吧
Jake: As soon as possible.
Alice:尽快
Alice: As soon as possible.
Jake:吃完吃完收拾收拾
Jake: Finish eating and tidy up.
Jake:我开始扫
Jake: I'll start sweeping.
Jake:你们在外面待着
Jake: You guys stay outside.
Alice:那我去收拾一下下
Alice: Then I'll go and tidy up a bit.
Jake:或者在4月30
Jake: Or on April 30th
Lucia: 还要再扫一遍
Lucia: We need to sweep again
Jake:不要扫
Jake: No sweeping
Jake:扫一遍你们装饰之后的就长不一样了
Jake: If you sweep, your decorations will look different
Jake:呵呵呵是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Alice:找不同
Alice: Spot the difference
Lucia: 有一些有一些
Lucia: A little bit, a little bit
Lucia: 美容值掉下来了
Lucia: The beauty value dropped
Lucia: 我再回去粘一下
Lucia: I'll stick it back
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah
Jake:好嘞那我先扫你的
Jake: Alright, I'll sweep yours first
Jake:先扫你的屋子哦
Jake: I'll sweep your room first
Tasha: 扫啊就现在
Tasha: Sweep now?
Lucia: 你说我粘好之后哦
Lucia: You mean after I stick it back?
Tasha: 就是扫装饰完的是吗
Tasha: Sweep after decorating, right?
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Alice:我的也快扫吧因为我那个胶
Alice: Sweep mine too, because my glue
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh right
Alice:他老掉对对对
Alice: It keeps falling off, right, right
Lucia:  我今天早上起来发现他又掉了
Lucia: I found it fell off again this morning
Lucia: 那我以为不用了
Lucia: I thought it wasn't needed
Lucia: 我就没粘
Lucia: So I didn't stick it back
Lucia: 我想在上面粘一下然后再粘
Lucia: I want to stick it back on top and then again
Alice:我全都在粘
Alice: I'm sticking everything back
Jake:那我先扫二楼
Jake: Then I'll sweep the second floor first
Jake:我先扫你的屋子
Jake: I'll sweep your room first
Jake:然后你的屋子
Jake: Then your room
Jake:二楼就
Jake: The second floor
Jake:我在二楼的时候你们就在一楼待着
Jake: When I'm on the second floor, you guys stay on the first floor
Jake:然后你可以在一楼再贴一贴
Jake: Then you can stick things on the first floor
Jake:我下来的时候你就上去
Jake: When I come down, you go up
Alice:可以可以
Alice: Okay, okay
Jake:就这么回事
Jake: That's how it is
Alice:在院子应该也行都一样
Alice: It should be fine in the yard too, all the same
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Jake:哼哼你倒一点
Jake: Hmm, pour some for me
Lucia: 你给我倒点
Lucia: Pour me some
Lucia: 我给你拿点别的
Lucia: Let me get you something else.
Lucia: 哈哈应该还有别的吗
Lucia: Haha, there should be something else, right?
Jake:哦到位了
Jake: Oh, that's perfect.
Jake:挺好走一遍流程
Jake: Great, let's go through the process once.
Lucia: 我去看看还有啥喝的给你拿一点
Lucia: I'll go check what else we have to drink and get you some.
Jake:哼哼找找
Jake: Hmm, look around.
Jake:喝
Jake: Drink.
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Drink?
Jake:喝水里面有可乐喝
Jake: There's cola in the water.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 可乐好像也没了
Shure: Seems like the cola is gone too.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 我的灯还亮着吗
Lucia: Is my light still on?
Jake:不亮了
Jake: It's off.
Lucia: 我刚突然反应过来
Lucia: I just suddenly realized.
Lucia: 我好像我把线拿了下来
Lucia: I think I took the cable down.
Lucia: 但是没有接上
Lucia: But didn't plug it back in.
Jake:哦充电宝那边有很多哦
Jake: Oh, there are plenty of power banks over there.
Lucia: 没事充电宝在这哦
Lucia: It's fine, the power bank is here.
Jake:哈哈哈你的任务太多了
Jake: Hahaha, you have too many tasks.
Lucia: 处理的任务太多了
Lucia: Handling too many tasks.
Lucia: 我现在把这个关了
Lucia: I'll turn this off now.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake:先倒点桃汁
Jake: Pour some peach juice first.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:请能来个新的吧
Jake: Can we get a new one, please?
Jake:咱不差杯子
Jake: We're not short on cups.
Lucia: 我先把这个看下
Lucia: Let me check this first.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Drink?
Jake:他他好像都没有喝
Jake: It seems like he hasn't drunk any.
Jake:你喝吗这些东西
Jake: Do you drink these things?
Katrina: 我喝矿泉水
Katrina: I drink mineral water.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 因为我来北京什么的
Shure: Because when I came to Beijing and all...
Jake:喝吗
Jake: Drink?
Alice:我手机在这吗
Alice: Is my phone here?
Shure: 剩下也不用那什么
Shure: No need for the rest of that.
Shure: 他这个能查到多多少啊
Shure: How much can he check?
Lucia: 好像没有啊
Lucia: Seems like it's not here.
Jake:没看着
Jake: Didn't see it.
Shure: 更多的话
Shure: More, if possible.
Alice:嗯那我扔哪了
Alice: Hmm, where did I throw it?
其他人：我这直接到13年了
Others: I got up to 2013.
Shure: 我到不了
Shure: I can't reach it.
Shure: 我前面肯定更有啊
Shure: There must be more in front.
Shure: 去解锁哎呀
Shure: Go unlock it, oh man.
Shure: 还要会员
Shure: Need a membership.
Shure: 我去你
Shure: Oh come on.
其他人：不用啊
Others: No need for that.
Jake:汇源
Jake: Huiyuan.
其他人：我历史上都没有啊
Others: I don't have that in my history.
Shure: 那可能从那时候就开始有了
Shure: Maybe it started from that time.
其他人：乱飞在这里
Others: It's flying around here.
其他人：乱飞
Others: Flying around.
Shure: 优惠券我找一找
Shure: Let me find the coupon.
其他人：大周两个国家
Others: Great Zhou, two countries.
其他人：两个3个两个
Others: Two, three, two.
其他人：非常最多
Others: The most.
Jake:你们一半的饭
Jake: You guys eat half the meal.
Jake:只吃一半
Jake: Only half.
Jake:一半的一半是吧
Jake: Half of the half, right?
Jake:嗯这你就是健胃超市便
Jake: Hmm, that's your digestion aid.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Katrina: 哦就你就是健胃消食片
Katrina: Oh, so that's your digestion aid.
Shure: 我们两个
Shure: The two of us.
Shure: 我们两个都吃完了
Shure: The two of us finished it all.
Jake:加上了两个健胃消食片
Jake: Plus two digestion aids.
Shure: 对我还
Shure: Yeah, I also...
Shure: 我还加餐两个健胃消食片呢
Shure: I also added two digestion aids.
Jake:对嗯
Jake: Right, hmm.
其他人：你看18 对在上高中
Others: Look, 18, still in high school.
其他人：完全没有出门
Others: Never went out.
Katrina: 我妈在干啥
Katrina: What is my mom doing?
Jake:这啥呀这是
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 洋葱
Lucia: Onion.
Jake:炒洋葱是吧
Jake: Stir-fried onions, right?
Jake:嗯这道菜
Jake: Hmm, this dish
Lucia: 然后还有回锅肉
Lucia: And there's also twice-cooked pork.
Katrina: 这是回锅肉
Katrina: This is twice-cooked pork.
Jake:回锅肉没有找到了
Jake: I can't find the twice-cooked pork.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 嗨
Katrina: Hi.
Katrina: 你在哪呢
Katrina: Where are you?
Katrina: 你搁哪呢
Katrina: Where are you at?
Katrina: 在新家
Katrina: At the new house.
Katrina: 你看昨天给你拍照片
Katrina: Did you see the photos I took for you yesterday?
Katrina: 我这说话不利索
Katrina: I'm not very fluent.
Katrina: 呵呵我说昨天给你发的照片看了不
Katrina: Haha, did you see the photos I sent you yesterday?
Katrina: 然后我没发吗
Katrina: Did I not send them?
Katrina: 他们装扮的都好好看
Katrina: They all dressed up so nicely.
Katrina: 我以后也要搞成这个样子
Katrina: I want to dress up like that in the future.
Katrina: 我明天早上把我买的一些东西寄回去
Katrina: I'll send back some of the things I bought tomorrow morning.
Katrina: 啊上次买的那衣服寄到家了吗
Katrina: Did the clothes I bought last time arrive at home?
Katrina: 哦上次
Katrina: Oh, last time...
Katrina: 你知道那两大坨寄快递好多钱吗
Katrina: Do you know how much it cost to send those two big packages?
Katrina: 对啊我跟你说过了
Katrina: Yeah, I told you.
Katrina: 原来超便宜
Katrina: It was actually super cheap.
Katrina: 今天22号
Katrina: Today is the 22nd.
Katrina: 今天休息一天
Katrina: Taking a day off today.
Katrina: 我们戴眼镜就是干活
Katrina: We're wearing glasses, just working.
Katrina: 嗯吃回锅肉
Katrina: Hmm, eating twice-cooked pork.
Katrina: 我爹呢
Katrina: Where's my dad?
Lucia: 我觉得只要出境的人都在干活
Lucia: I think everyone who's on camera is working.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:嗯确实确实
Jake: Yeah, definitely.
Katrina: 我爹在装空调
Katrina: My dad is installing the air conditioner.
Lucia: 那个大学习全身是什么
Lucia: What is the "Youth University" all about?
Katrina: 这白的是什么
Katrina: What is this white thing?
Katrina: 这是冰箱吗
Katrina: Is this a fridge?
Katrina: 这个卡其色是什么东西啊
Katrina: What is this khaki thing?
Jake:青年青年
Jake: Youth, youth.
Lucia: 青年大学习
Lucia: Youth University.
Katrina: 没有你在我有多难熬
Katrina: It's so hard without you here.
Katrina: 看不清啊
Katrina: Can't see clearly.
Katrina: 这啥颜色啊
Katrina: What color is this?
Lucia: OK但是其实我上学那会
Lucia: OK, but actually when I was in school
Lucia: 就是我认识的别的学校同学都有的
Lucia: other students from different schools I knew had it
Katrina: 都行啊都行啊
Katrina: Anything works, anything works
Katrina: 现在我已经会装饰我的房间了
Katrina: Now I can decorate my room
Lucia: 以现就不太熟
Lucia: Now it's not very familiar
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh
Lucia:  我为什么会觉得他叫全民大学习呢
Lucia: Why do I think it's called "National Learning"?
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure
Jake:确实结论上是全民大学习
Jake: It is indeed "National Learning" in conclusion
Shure: 哎不是
Shure: Hey, no
Shure: 那我就去看一下
Shure: I'll go check it out
Shure: 我现在卧槽
Shure: I'm like, whoa
Katrina: 可以啊你搞绿色就行
Katrina: Sure, just go with green
Katrina: 反正我买的东西都是绿色系
Katrina: Anyway, everything I bought is green
Katrina: 好的好的没问题
Katrina: Alright, alright, no problem
Katrina: （歌词）没有你在我有多难熬
Katrina: (Lyrics) It's so hard without you here
Lucia: 我们虽然没有那个青年大学习
Lucia: Although we don't have that "Youth Learning"
Lucia: 但我们有语课堂
Lucia: But we have language classes
Katrina: 收拾收拾房间
Katrina: Tidying up the room
Katrina: 洗洗碗睡睡觉
Katrina: Washing dishes, going to sleep
Lucia: 就是怎么形容它有点像Cosera
Lucia: It's kind of like Coursera in a way
Katrina: 是要收拾收拾东西
Katrina: Need to tidy things up
Lucia: 就是学校老师会把那些课件
Lucia: The teachers upload course materials there
Lucia: 之类的传到上面
Lucia: and stuff like that
其他人：我我其实不太用它买机票
Others: I actually don't use it much to buy tickets
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK
Lucia:  然后就是需要在那上面看那个课件啊
Lucia: Then you need to watch those materials on it
Katrina: 是啊回去写毕社了都
Katrina: Yeah, going back to write the thesis
Katrina: 不习惯了都
Katrina: Not used to it
Lucia: 然后我每次看完也像科32一样
Lucia: Every time I finish, it's like Coursera
Lucia: 他还有那种选择题
Lucia: It even has multiple-choice questions
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 嗯但是鉴于我
Lucia: Yeah, but considering I
Katrina: 毕业还是没问题
Katrina: Graduating is still fine
Katrina: 能毕业这么呵呵
Katrina: Being able to graduate, haha
Jake:在有GPT了就好多了
Jake: It's much better with GPT
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 我们在这生物
Lucia: We are here in biology
Lucia: 生物学原理
Lucia: Principles of Biology
Katrina: 肯定能毕业的呀
Katrina: Of course, I can graduate.
Lucia: 还是生物学原理
Lucia: It's still the principles of biology.
Jake:哈哈哈就学这些东西
Jake: Hahaha, just studying this stuff.
Lucia: 对我们还学这个
Lucia: Yeah, we're still studying this.
Lucia: 没想到
Lucia: Didn't expect that.
Jake:没想到
Jake: Didn't expect that.
Katrina: 这我爹吗
Katrina: Is this my dad?
Lucia: 然后这个课也有
Lucia: And this course too.
Lucia: 那个语课堂都不会
Lucia: That language class doesn't even...
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我爹这头好搞笑
Katrina: Hahaha, my dad's head is so funny.
Jake:我们北游的课比较离谱的
Jake: Our courses at Beiyou are pretty outrageous.
Jake:就是所有的学科都要学
Jake: We have to study all subjects.
Jake:学傅里叶变换
Jake: Learning Fourier transform.
Jake:傅里叶变换就学日语学
Jake: Learning Fourier transform in Japanese class.
Jake:学俄语也要学复利页变换
Jake: Even in Russian class, we study Fourier transform.
Lucia: 为什么呀
Lucia: Why?
Lucia: 用不到啊
Lucia: It's not useful.
Jake:就是嘿嘿
Jake: Just, hehe.
Jake:可能翻译著作吧
Jake: Maybe for translating works.
Lucia: 翻译
Lucia: Translation?
Lucia: 翻译数学著作吗
Lucia: Translating math works?
Jake:通信原理
Jake: Communication principles.
Jake:通信的东西
Jake: Communication stuff.
Lucia: 统计学呀
Lucia: Statistics.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 我学盖桶的时候学的不太好
Lucia: I wasn't good at learning Gauss.
Lucia: 但是学那个ignometrics
Lucia: But I was good at learning ignometrics.
Katrina: 我爹叼都不叼我一眼呢
Katrina: My dad doesn't even look at me.
Lucia: 中文叫什么
Lucia: What's it called in Chinese?
Lucia: 计量经济学
Lucia: Econometrics.
Lucia: 你看我其实英文没有变好
Lucia: You see, my English hasn't improved much.
Lucia: 但是中文变差了
Lucia: But my Chinese has gotten worse.
Katrina: 忙吧
Katrina: Busy, huh.
Katrina: 忙点好
Katrina: Being busy is good.
Jake:没英文英文变好了
Jake: No, your English has improved.
Jake:英文好了
Jake: Your English is better.
Lucia: 速度完全赶不上我的同学
Lucia: But I still can't keep up with my classmates.
Jake:哈哈哈没关系
Jake: Hahaha, it's okay.
Jake:混着说
Jake: Just mix it up.
Lucia: 然后学那个计量的时候
Lucia: And then when I was learning that measurement stuff
Lucia: 因为很多东西概统学过一次
Lucia: Because a lot of things were covered once in statistics
Shure: 不是我妈让我去干这个去
Shure: It wasn’t my mom who made me do this
Lucia: 嗯然后于是就突然学了很多
Lucia: Yeah, so then I suddenly learned a lot
Katrina: 咱还有水果吃吗
Katrina: Do we still have any fruit left?
Jake:有水果汁
Jake: We have fruit juice
Katrina: 嗯哈哈哈
Katrina: Hmm, haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 这是什么水果哈
Katrina: What kind of fruit is this?
Jake:这什么水果
Jake: What kind of fruit is this?
Jake:双鸭三鸭这是
Jake: Twin ducks, triple ducks?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈哎呀
Jake: Hahaha, oh my
Lucia: AI能反应过来吗
Lucia: Can AI react to this?
Jake:确实没有水果吃
Jake: There really isn’t any fruit to eat
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 这要说话带口音的话怎么办呀
Lucia: What if you speak with an accent?
Lucia: 只和吃的好
Lucia: Just eat well
Shure: 明天是初几啊
Shure: What day is tomorrow?
Katrina: 给你点赞
Katrina: Thumbs up for you
Jake:嗯哼哼差别不大
Jake: Uh-huh, not much difference
Shure: 明天是初五
Shure: Tomorrow is the fifth
其他人：我特地看的明天是15
Others: I specifically checked, tomorrow is the 15th
其他人：哎呀我真烦你们
Others: Oh my, I’m so annoyed with you guys
Shure: 那你去呗
Shure: Then you go ahead
Shure: 我又不是没让你
Shure: I never stopped you
Shure: 那你买不就不用我买了吗
Shure: If you buy it, I don’t have to
Katrina: 好看好看
Katrina: Looks good, looks good
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
Katrina: 好看很高级
Katrina: Looks very high-end
Jake:嗯就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly
Lucia: 如果是很很很传统的方言是头这个词
Lucia: If it’s a very very traditional dialect, it’s the word "head"
Katrina: 好看你自己开心就好
Katrina: Looks good, as long as you’re happy
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yep
Lucia: 这叫啥
Lucia: What’s this called?
Katrina: 你自己的钱
Katrina: It’s your money
Jake:啥对
Jake: What, right?
Jake:这是啥对这是
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 这是啥这是
Lucia: What’s this?
Jake:哈哈哈哈他确实不知道这是啥对吧
Jake: Hahaha, he really doesn't know what this is, right?
Katrina: 把我们家搞成五星级酒店了
Katrina: You've turned our home into a five-star hotel.
Shure: 你猜猜她这么大还能求什么
Shure: Guess what she can still wish for at her age?
Jake:为为为什么
Jake: Wh-why?
Lucia: 摇头脑对吧
Lucia: Shake your head, right?
Jake:嗯对啊
Jake: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 不知道为啥
Lucia: Don't know why.
Jake:他为什么叫撒
Jake: Why is it called that?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Jake:一般会怎么用呢
Jake: How is it usually used?
Jake:就是我我撒上有个撒
Jake: It's like, I have this thing...
Katrina: 哇塞这么
Katrina: Wow, really...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 所以有一个笑话
Lucia: So there's a joke.
Lucia: 就是有一个陕西人走进医院
Lucia: There's this guy from Shaanxi who walks into a hospital.
Lucia: 对医生说医生
Lucia: He says to the doctor, "Doctor..."
Lucia: 我撒疼
Lucia: "I have pain here."
Lucia:   然后医生说你撒疼我怎么能知道呢
Lucia: And the doctor says, "You have pain here? How would I know?"
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:哼你爱咋疼咋疼
Jake: Hmph, you can have pain however you like.
Lucia: 但其实现在我觉得
Lucia: But actually, now I think...
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 哎你忘掉我刚刚没有跟你说过
Shure: Hey, forget what I just told you.
Lucia: 就是即使老一辈的基本上也都说疼OK
Lucia: Even the older generation basically says "pain" now, okay?
Shure: 然后我说我要去买
Shure: And then I said I was going to buy...
Jake:OK实在不好用这个词对不
Jake: OK, it's not good to use this word, right?
Shure: 他说哎我正好买了
Shure: He said, "Hey, I just bought it."
Lucia: 是不是很好用
Lucia: Isn't it very useful?
Jake:对哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, hahaha.
Lucia: 虽然我们家就是不
Lucia: Even though in our home...
Lucia: 就是平常都说普通话
Lucia: we usually speak Mandarin.
Lucia: 但是我觉得我感觉啊
Lucia: But I feel, I think...
Lucia: 就即使你是陕西有时候也反应不过来
Lucia: Even if you’re from Shaanxi, sometimes you don't get it right away.
Lucia: 我会这么觉得啊
Lucia: That's what I think.
Katrina: 好看
Katrina: Looks good.
Katrina: 有点像阿姨家的风格
Katrina: It kind of looks like Auntie's style.
Jake:应该是东北东北话
Jake: It should be Northeast dialect.
Jake:然后以前陕西那边没什么东北人
Jake: There weren't many people from the Northeast in Shaanxi back then.
Jake:就还没还好
Jake: So it was okay.
Jake:哈哈是吧东北就是不去陕西
Jake: Haha, right, people from the northeast just don't go to Shaanxi.
Shure: 东北人又怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with people from the northeast?
Jake:因为陕西里边他们把头叫啥
Jake: Because in Shaanxi, what do they call their head?
Lucia: 啥就是最最最传统陕西方言的话
Lucia: Well, if we speak in the most traditional Shaanxi dialect...
Katrina: 好看内好看内
Katrina: It looks good, it looks good.
Jake:就是因为这个
Jake: It's because of this.
Lucia: 就是这是啥
Lucia: So, what is this?
Jake:就是这是啥
Jake: So, what is this?
Jake:但是因为因为以前陕西东北人对
Jake: But because, you know, back then in Shaanxi, people from the northeast...
Jake:这是啥
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 应该是这样
Lucia: It should be like this.
Lucia: 我妈给我讲的我可以再找他合作
Lucia: My mom told me about it, and I can work with him again.
Katrina: 现在家里有味道吗
Katrina: Does your house smell now?
Lucia: 但好像确实是这样
Lucia: But it seems to be true.
Lucia: 因为我听完之后我去
Lucia: Because after I heard it, I went to...
Lucia:  问了我姥
Lucia: Ask my grandma.
Katrina: 不是要通风3个月吗
Katrina: Didn't you need to ventilate for three months?
Lucia: 婆但是其实就是现在
Lucia: Grandma, but actually, it's just that now...
Lucia: ：反正基本上都不能
Lucia: Basically, you can't...
Katrina: 你买个测甲醛测一下
Katrina: You should get a formaldehyde tester.
Jake:那陕西的就是陕西自己也有啥是吗
Jake: So Shaanxi has something of its own too, right?
Katrina: 那你每天都通风吗
Katrina: Do you ventilate every day?
Jake:他们管你叫什么吗
Jake: What do they call you?
Lucia: 有吧我觉得有
Lucia: I think so.
Jake:有啥哦
Jake: What do they call you?
Lucia: 只不过跟普通话这个啥
Lucia: It's just that compared to Mandarin, this...
Jake:可能音也不是完全一样
Jake: The proShure's GFciation might not be exactly the same.
Lucia: 有有可以啊
Lucia: Yes, yes, it could be.
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: It could be.
Lucia: 比如说没听清你说什么就就会说13
Lucia: For example, if you didn't hear clearly, you'd say "13."
Jake:哦那就是有
Jake: Oh, so it exists.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:哈哈很地道
Jake: Haha, very authentic.
Jake:很地道了
Jake: Very authentic.
Katrina: 看我们在外面吃饭
Katrina: Look, we're eating outside.
Lucia: 所以我们还有水果吃吗嗯
Lucia: So, do we still have fruit to eat?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 每天穿个睡衣垫个拖鞋
Katrina: Every day, wearing pajamas and slippers.
Lucia: 楼上好像还有一个山竹
Lucia: Seems like there's a mangosteen upstairs.
Jake:哦可以
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Jake:山竹可能能发个分个8本
Jake: Maybe we can divide the mangosteen into eight portions.
Katrina: 对啊然后昨天邀请  他们来玩
Katrina: Yeah, and then we invited Du Zhuoyun and the others to play yesterday.
Katrina: 上次我也没来
Katrina: I didn't come last time either.
Katrina: 上次我有家教
Katrina: Last time I had tutoring.
Katrina: 本来每个人就是邀请一到两个
Katrina: Originally, everyone was supposed to invite one or two people.
Katrina: 邀请多了
Katrina: But we invited too many.
Katrina: 那就我们都准备
Katrina: So we all had to prepare.
Katrina: 不准备不够啊
Katrina: If we didn't prepare enough, it wouldn't be enough.
Katrina: 他们要做甜点啊什么的
Katrina: They had to make desserts and stuff.
Katrina: 开地铁来的
Katrina: They came by subway.
Katrina: 两个小时
Katrina: It took two hours.
Jake:他从哪来的
Jake: Where did he come from?
Katrina: 北京就是这样啊
Katrina: That's how it is in Beijing.
Katrina: 通勤时间很长
Katrina: The commute time is very long.
Katrina: 他从清华来五道口
Katrina: He came from Tsinghua to Wudaokou.
Katrina: 什么叫浪费别人的时间
Katrina: What do you mean wasting other people's time?
Katrina: 这个是一起过来玩
Katrina: We all came to play together.
Katrina:    刘凯琳也在家教啊
Katrina: Liu Kailin is also tutoring.
Katrina:    还没有    熟呢好吧
Katrina: Liu Kailin isn't as familiar with Du Zhuoyun, okay?
Katrina:    还没有    熟啊
Katrina: Liu Kailin isn't as familiar with Du Zhuoyun.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 大学聊的不是那么多
Katrina: We didn't talk much in college.
Katrina: 而且人家也有女朋友呀
Katrina: And he has a girlfriend.
Jake:控制他我今天早上修硕他们俩
Jake: Control him, this morning Shure and the others...
Jake:他们俩今天把这个收拾完了
Jake: They cleaned this up today.
Katrina: 12点
Katrina: Until 12 o'clock.
Jake:然后我早上一看
Jake: Then this morning I looked.
Jake:我靠我看这桌子
Jake: I saw this table...
Jake:这桌子空了
Jake: The table was empty.
Jake:吓我一跳
Jake: It scared me.
Jake:我以为风先吹走了
Jake: I thought the wind blew it away.
Jake:呵呵没事咱就给他
Jake: Haha, no worries, we just...
Katrina: 每天都晚到12点
Katrina: Every day until 12 o'clock.
Katrina: 对啊今天早上睡到11点半
Katrina: Yeah, I slept until 11:30 this morning.
Katrina: 嘿
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 嘿又不喊我起床很爽啊
Katrina: Hey, you didn't wake me up, it was great.
Lucia: 这个没气
Lucia: This is out of gas.
Lucia: 给你倒满点
Lucia: Let me fill it up for you.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 又开始了
Katrina: It's starting again.
Katrina: 你拿我当你的镜子呢
Katrina: You're treating me like your mirror.
Jake:嗯没关系
Jake: Hmm, it's fine.
Katrina: 好看啊
Katrina: Looks good.
Katrina: 感觉你的胶原蛋白比我还多
Katrina: Feels like you have more collagen than I do.
Katrina: 我明天下午要去一趟雍和宫
Katrina: I'm going to Yonghe Temple tomorrow afternoon.
Katrina: 我要去还愿去
Katrina: I'm going to fulfill my vow.
Katrina: 还愿啊你当时求的东西准了
Katrina: Fulfill my vow, because what I prayed for came true.
Katrina: 你不得去还个愿吗
Katrina: Don't you need to fulfill your vow too?
Katrina: 我自己去还原
Katrina: I'll go fulfill it myself.
Jake:还愿多少钱
Jake: How much does it cost to fulfill a vow?
Katrina: 不要钱去那磕个头
Katrina: It doesn't cost anything, just bow.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 优惠宫不要门票吧
Katrina: No entrance fee for Yonghe Temple, right?
Katrina: 哦好像要门票 5块钱
Katrina: Oh, there is an entrance fee, 5 yuan.
Jake:那烧香多少钱
Jake: How much for incense?
Katrina: 烧香是自己
Katrina: Incense is your own.
Katrina: 烧香是带的
Katrina: You bring your own incense.
Katrina: 门票是带的
Katrina: The ticket includes it.
Katrina: 明天晚上就住北郊附近
Katrina: I'll stay near the northern suburb tomorrow night.
Katrina: 又跟上紫薇那
Katrina: And catch up with Violet there.
Katrina: 个他哪天没时间呀
Katrina: He doesn't have time that day.
Katrina: 就在他们学校旁边
Katrina: It's just next to their school.
Katrina: 他只是从宿舍走出来而已
Katrina: He only needs to walk out of the dormitory.
Katrina: 哇这是什么年轻小伙子呀
Katrina: Wow, what a young guy!
Katrina: 哈哈像那种30岁的企业家
Katrina: Haha, looks like a 30-year-old entrepreneur.
Katrina: 我爸我爸是奶油小生哈哈
Katrina: My dad, my dad is a handsome young man, haha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 打麻将我这
Katrina: Playing mahjong here.
Katrina: 这个叫什么
Katrina: What's this called?
Katrina: 这个叫爱好
Katrina: It's called a hobby.
Katrina: 能使人永葆年轻
Katrina: It keeps people young.
Katrina: 我要去洗衣服
Katrina: I need to do laundry.
Katrina: 没有你在
Katrina: Without you here.
Katrina: 老妈给你看我昨天做的那个
Katrina: Mom, look at what I made yesterday.
Katrina: 我昨天做的那个花
Katrina: The flower I made yesterday.
Katrina: 我昨天拍卖卖了几个嘿嘿
Katrina: I auctioned off a few yesterday, hehe.
Katrina: 就是他们来的好朋友买啊
Katrina: Friends who came over bought it.
Katrina: 就是我们的那个EGO币
Katrina: 就是那个贴纸
Katrina: It's that sticker.
Katrina: 给你看我的房间
Katrina: Let me show you my room.
Katrina: 我买了个这个
Katrina: 看
Katrina: 看我的房间
Katrina: 我的我可以看到他们楼下
Katrina: 画的
Katrina: 这是我的
Katrina: 这是我自己家的娃娃
Katrina: 看我的房间
Katrina: 唉唉你能不能跟我说话专心一点
Katrina: 你一会跟老爸说话一会跟我说话的
Katrina: 那
Katrina: 不是挺好看的呀
Katrina: 怎么不好看了
Katrina: 买个娃娃
Katrina: 换个4件
Katrina: 套就会好看很多好吗
Katrina: 怎么乱了
Katrina: 我房间这么好
Katrina: 懂什么你
Katrina: 怎么了这么好看
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 这个是民宿里带的
Katrina: This came with the homestay.
Katrina: 这东西买了也寄不回去啊
Katrina: You can't buy this and mail it back.
Katrina: 买了一些装饰画
Katrina: I bought some decorative paintings.
Katrina: 些娃娃全部都是绿色
Katrina: All these dolls are green.
Katrina: 看见没有
Katrina: See?
Katrina: 我给你看其他人的房间
Katrina: Let me show you other people's rooms.
Katrina: 他们搞可好看
Katrina: They look really nice.
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmm...
Katrina: 我们在这唱卡拉OK呢
Katrina: We're singing karaoke here.
Katrina: 哦给你看我做的
Katrina: Oh, let me show you what I made.
Katrina: 这是他们做的蛋糕看见
Katrina: This is the cake they made, see?
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK.
Katrina: 这我还买了个这个
Katrina: I also bought this.
Jake:对对对你边录边删都可以
Jake: Yeah, yeah, you can record and delete as you go.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Sure.
Katrina: 就几块钱
Katrina: It only costs a few bucks.
Katrina: 还我的风铃还没做完
Katrina: And my wind chime isn't finished yet.
Katrina: 这是我压的花
Katrina: These are the flowers I pressed.
Katrina: 哎这怎么变色了
Katrina: Hey, why did they change color?
Katrina: 哇这个好看
Katrina: Wow, this one looks nice.
Katrina: 这我做的
Katrina: I made this.
Katrina: 这是我的香薰
Katrina: This is my aromatherapy.
Katrina: 它就可以当一个小夜灯
Katrina: It can also be used as a night light.
Katrina: 插电就可以当小夜灯
Katrina: Just plug it in, and it can be a night light.
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 其他人房间我不太好进去
Katrina: I don't really go into other people's rooms.
Katrina: 我给你拍照片
Katrina: I'll take a picture for you.
Katrina: 等会他要开始扫了吗
Katrina: Wait, is he about to start sweeping?
Lucia: 呃应该还没有呢
Lucia: Uh, I don't think so yet.
Lucia: 没事我们还可以先整理整理
Lucia: No worries, we can organize a bit more.
Lucia: 我也要整理一下
Lucia: I need to tidy up too.
Katrina: 这是我们的二楼
Katrina: This is our second floor.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 全部坐在这坐地
Katrina: Everyone sits here on the floor.
Lucia: 哎我刚看到你也挂了小旗子
Lucia: Hey, I just saw you hung a small flag too.
Katrina: 嗯我也有一个小旗子
Katrina: Yeah, I have a little flag too.
Lucia: 啊哈
Lucia: Aha.
Katrina: 我是动物世界的小旗子哈哈哈
Katrina: I'm the little flag of the animal world, haha.
Lucia: 好看
Lucia: Looks good.
Katrina: 哎呀你猜我有多爱
Katrina: Oh, guess how much I love it.
Katrina: 看康乃馨
Katrina: Look at the carnations.
Katrina: 我给你买点呗
Katrina: I'll buy some for you.
Katrina: 这个东西又很便宜
Katrina: This thing is really cheap too.
Katrina: 哎这几个花瓶我也寄回去算了
Katrina: Hey, I'll just send these vases back home.
Katrina: 因为到时候他那个我们也带不走
Katrina: Because we won't be able to take them with us later.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 你看你看这个地方这一片都是别墅
Katrina: Look, this whole area is full of villas.
Katrina: 你看隔的多近的
Katrina: Look how close they are.
Katrina: 这是别人家的就直接
Katrina: This is someone else's, just right next to us.
Katrina: 这是我们院子
Katrina: This is our yard.
Katrina: 这是别人家
Katrina: This is someone else's.
Katrina: 这一排全是别墅
Katrina: This whole row is villas.
Katrina: 对啊都是民宿
Katrina: Yeah, all of them are B&Bs.
Katrina: 都是基本上都是租给大家嘛
Katrina: They're basically all rented out to people.
Katrina: 就是旁边是环球影城嘛
Katrina: Because Universal Studios is nearby.
Katrina: 这边就是民宿
Katrina: And this area is full of B&Bs.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 他们做的小狗你看
Katrina: Look at the little dog they made.
Katrina: 放在门口
Katrina: Placed it by the door.
Katrina: 自己做的
Katrina: Made it themselves.
Katrina: 他们用纸箱厉害吧
Katrina: They used a cardboard box, isn't that impressive?
Katrina: 我做那个压花也可好了
Katrina: I made some pressed flowers, they turned out great too.
Katrina: 这我昨天我拍卖买到的
Katrina: I got this at an auction yesterday.
Katrina: 这是一个胶
Katrina: This is a glue.
Katrina: 片这是一个朋友带过来的
Katrina: This film was brought over by a friend.
Katrina: 就是要用光才能打出
Katrina: You need light to develop it.
Katrina: 这是大海
Katrina: This is the sea.
Katrina: 这买了两个种子
Katrina: I bought two seeds.
Katrina: 就是我们互相拍卖嘛
Katrina: We auction off items to each other.
Katrina: 这个就当我们的货币
Katrina: We use these as our currency.
Katrina: 不是用真的钱
Katrina: Not real money.
Katrina: 只是带大家做游戏而已
Katrina: Just to play games with everyone.
Katrina: 你这人真的很没有情趣
Katrina: You really have no sense of fun.
Katrina: 不想跟你说话
Katrina: I don't want to talk to you.
Katrina: 昨
Katrina: Yester-
Katrina: 这个这个的
Katrina: This, this.
Katrina: 房间超好看
Katrina: The room looks amazing.
Katrina: 你懂啥呀
Katrina: What do you know?
Katrina: 他房间可漂亮了
Katrina: His room is really beautiful.
Katrina: 他们几个女生的手都很巧
Katrina: The girls are all very skillful.
Katrina: 心都很细
Katrina: And very meticulous.
Katrina: 这做的特别好看
Katrina: Their work is especially beautiful.
Katrina: 你知道昨天
Katrina: You know yesterday,
Katrina: 我以为我的房间已经装饰的挺好看的
Katrina: I thought my room was already nicely decorated.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 因为第一个参观是我的房间
Katrina: Because mine was the first to be visited.
Katrina: 然后呢我一推开他们几个的门
Katrina: But when I opened the doors to their rooms,
Katrina: 我说我靠我这个太太简单了
Katrina: I was like, wow, mine is way too simple.
Katrina: 就是明显的那种理工科的那种感觉
Katrina: It obviously had that techy vibe, you know?
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 我我这个装饰
Katrina: My decorations,
Katrina: 跟楼下那个男生装的一模一样
Katrina: Looked just like the ones the guys downstairs did.
Katrina: 我跟你说我真的我来这边玩
Katrina: I'm telling you, when I came here to play,
Katrina: 我天天跟那几个工作人员
Katrina: I hung out with those staff members,
Katrina: 那几个男生玩
Katrina: Those guys.
Katrina: 玩的比较多
Katrina: I played with them more.
Katrina: 因为都是兄弟
Katrina: Because we're all brothers.
Katrina: 都是哥们
Katrina: We're all buddies.
Katrina: 哇都是哥们啊
Katrina: Wow, we're all buddies.
Katrina: 爽的一特别搞笑
Katrina: It's so funny.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know what?
Katrina: 他们昨天
Katrina: Yesterday,
Katrina: 嗯杜卓宇走了以后
Katrina: after Du Zhuoyu left,
Katrina: 那几个哥们把我围在中间
Katrina: those guys surrounded me.
Katrina: 问我们俩什么关系
Katrina: They asked what our relationship was.
Katrina: 我说好朋友啊
Katrina: I said, we're good friends.
Katrina: 他说不是那个男的绝对喜欢你
Katrina: They said, no way, that guy definitely likes you.
Katrina: 我说你们别瞎说
Katrina: I said, don't talk nonsense.
Katrina: 哈哈哈把我笑死
Katrina: Haha, I laughed so hard.
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh...
Katrina: 我觉得就好朋友
Katrina: I think we're just good friends.
Katrina: 那他们就说什么他们第三视角看
Katrina: But they said, from their perspective,
Katrina: 这男的觉得喜欢你
Katrina: that guy likes you.
Katrina: 喜欢哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Likes you, hahaha.
Katrina: 我跟你说
Katrina: Let me tell you,
Katrina: 昨天修硕不是带着他女朋友来吗
Katrina: Shure brought his girlfriend yesterday, right?
Katrina: 他女朋友昨天喝多了
Katrina: His girlfriend got drunk yesterday.
Katrina: 就是我们自己调的果酒
Katrina: It was from the fruit wine we made ourselves.
Katrina: 他拉着我说姐妹你长这么漂亮
Katrina: She grabbed me and said, "Sister, you're so pretty."
Katrina: 每个人都该喜欢你
Katrina: "Everyone should like you."
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then,
Katrina: 只是我这是高兴的要死你知道吗
Katrina: I was so happy, you know?
Katrina: 我也不知道
Katrina: I don't even know.
Katrina: 所以他们昨天说杜卓宇喜欢
Katrina: So when they said Du Zhuoyu likes me yesterday,
Katrina: 我都很震惊
Katrina: I was shocked.
Katrina: 说不都是哥们吗
Katrina: I thought we were just buddies.
Katrina: 他们说玩游戏的时候
Katrina: They said, while we were playing games,
Katrina: 玩游戏的时候    一直在看我
Katrina: Du Zhuoyu kept looking at me.
Katrina: 看我干啥
Katrina: Why was he looking at me?
Katrina: 笑什么我是觉得很搞笑
Katrina: I thought it was funny.
Katrina: 我跟他没相处多长时间
Katrina: We haven't spent much time together.
Katrina: 怎么就喜欢我
Katrina: How could he like me?
Katrina: 这不搞笑吗
Katrina: Isn't that funny?
Katrina: 都是哥们啊都是哥
Katrina: We're all buddies, all buddies.
Katrina: 嗯都是哥们
Katrina: Yeah, we're all buddies.
Katrina: 你兄弟对你也太不好了吧
Katrina: Your brother is really not treating you well.
Katrina: 不是我爸穿这种衬衫真的挺帅的
Katrina: Actually, my dad looks really handsome in this kind of shirt.
Katrina: 有点像雷军
Katrina: He looks a bit like Lei Jun.
Katrina: 有点像那个雷军啊
Katrina: He looks a bit like Lei Jun, you know?
Katrina: 就是我觉得他穿这种
Katrina: I just think him wearing this...
Katrina: 嗯他要是再加一个西装
Katrina: If he adds a suit...
Katrina: 就像那种企业的老板了
Katrina: He would look like a company boss.